الازمه السياسيه الكبيره في سوريا الى اي
مدى تعطل عملكم كعمل انساني وعمل اغاثه
سواء في موضوع الزلزال او موضوع الكوليرا
او موضوع المشردين والمهجرين والنازحين من
بيوتهم كيف تقومون بعملكم في ظل وجود هذا
الصراع الداخلي السوري
لدينا من الزملاء الذين يعملون في سوريا
وقد عملوا هناك على مدار السنوات بالتعاون
مع هيئه الهلال الاحمر السوري وفي الوقت
ذاته وفي ظل الاوضاع الراهنه نرى انه امر
اساسي ان لا يتم تسييس المساعدات
الانسانيه او استخدامها كاداء حتى يستطيع
المحتاجون في اي مكان كانوا من تلقي
المساعدات الضروريه اذا نحن
تعاونا مع كافه الاطراف ذات العلاقه لضمان
توفير المساعدات وينبغي ان اقول ايضا اننا
شاهدنا تضامنا عالميا على نطاق واسع
الحقيقه
لستم الوحيدون الذين يطالبون بضروره عدم
تسييس العمل الاغاثي والانساني لكن في
سوريا واضح انه السيس يعني كان في تعطيل
من كل الجهات لوصول
العمليات الانقاذ كيف بتواجهوا هذه الازمه
كيف بتحلوها
منظمه انسانيه وبالتالي لا نخوض في اي
اعتبارات او جدل سياسي نحن ما نقوم به هو
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه وفي الاوضاع
التي يحتاج فيها الناس الوصول الى مساعدات
حيويه نقوم بالتعاون مع كافه الاطراف ذات
العلاقه لضمان تسليم المساعدات وهذا ما
نقوم به في الوقت الراهن رئيسنا
زارا سوريا خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
ونحن نتعاون مع كافه الاطراف على اساس هذا
المبدا
الانسان الذي ينبغي للا الاطفال والنساء
والكبار السن ان يحصلوا على المساعدات
التي هم بامسه الحاجه لديها لها ولدينا
الوسائل للقيام لذلك كون نرى هذا السخاء
الكبير في العالم وهذا ما نعمل عليه في
الوقت الرائع لا شك بانكم تقومون بما
تستطيعون في حل هذه الازمه الانسانيه
والاغاثيه لا اقصد الازمه السياسيه لكن
عندما تقول بانه رئيس صليب الاحمر كان في
سوريا كان في جهه النظام السوري ولا في
جهه المعارضه السوريه واذا ذهبت مساعدات
للنظام السوري يقال بانها لا تذهب
للمعارضه والعكس صحيح من هنا تاتي هذه
الازمه في غاثه المنكوبين
الفيزيتين في الواقع وزاره الكثير من
المناطق في سوريا وقد تعاونت مع السلطات
وما نلاحظه اننا نحاول بانفسنا تقييم
الاحتياجات على الارض وعلى هذا الاساس
نقدم استجابه ولكننا تجدون هناك ايضا اشد
ارجت الى المساعده التي قدمناها لمستشفى
حلب لا نقوم بذلك مره واحده وانما نعود
الى مستشفى لنتاكد من المساعدات وصلت الى
المحتاجين اليها من
المصابين ومن اجل ذلك نحتاج للوصول وهذا
دائما ما نناقشه مع كافه الاطراف ذات
العلاقه حتى نحصل على الوصول لتقديم
المساعدات لمن يحتاج اليه
تستطيعون برغم العراقيل ان تقدموا مساعدات
هناك اثار هذا الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا هل
تتوقع انه ستنتهي في المستقبل القريب بناء
على خبرتكم وتجربتكم يعني